foreign
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
and welcome to another Friday Round
Table Extravaganza joining me today is
political commentator and proud
Floridian John cardillo and president of
the Brownstone Institute Jeffrey Tucker
gentlemen welcome back to the Reuben
report
good to be here I am glad to have you
both if only there was anything to talk
about this week if only anything had
happened in the world worth talking
about and uh yes we're going to talk
Trump and mostly media reaction to Trump
and then we're going to do a little bit
on some economic stuff as well but let's
just Dive Right In we don't have to
recap the entire indictment and all that
let's go into some of the media reaction
to Trump being indicted and the media
reaction to this yes Soros funded it's
true D.A out of New York City Alvin Breg
here is Andrea Mitchell on the televised
mental institution known as MS NBC
calling Trump racist because he doesn't
like Alvin Breg and it may or may not be
coincidental but both the D.A and the
judge are people of color or the judge
as judge hero was was ethnically
Hispanic I believe Latino and of course
the D.A is black so they have certainly
become targets of his in any case and
their families
guys I am so tired of this racializing
of everything and even as Andrea
Mitchell saying it you can feel that she
doesn't even believe it as she's choking
it out she's not even sure if the other
guy's Hispanic you know when we covered
this earlier in the week the way they
were racializing this whole thing it's
like we also played the State of the
Union Address that Trump gave a couple
years ago where he talked about lowest
all-time black and Latino unemployment
and everybody all the Democrats sat
there arms crossed as if they didn't
care about that sort of who cares right
so Jeffrey uh I'm starting to think that
this is projection more than anything
else what do you think uh yeah very well
could be there you know Donald Trump has
a huge and hardcore of black American
Support I was at a republican gathering
in Queens New York I don't know if you
know about Queens New York I am a long
Islander as as was John at one time I
grew up in Queens yeah oh well it was my
first foray into queens and uh it's got
a certain certain thing going a certain
attitude you know but anyway uh funny
accents and so on anyway about uh 20 or
30 of the people there were actually
from Harlem and very hardcore uh
supporters of trump and and and
patriotic and enthusiastic and you know
the race issue is not even a thing
anymore like if it ever was and and
currently Republican Politics the only
people who are making it a a thing are
are Trump's enemies so and it's
extremely divisive and very nasty and
really insufferable I mean if you want
if you want to find people who are fed
up with it and want to get away from all
this identity politics you're going to
find them in in the Republican party not
not in uh certainly not in the
mainstream Media or the Democratic uh
National Committee activists right and
you know Trump double blackmail support
last election it's not a huge amount I
think it was something like four percent
to eight percent but that when you
double anything and then you extrapolate
that over years things can change pretty
quickly John this is just like standard
101 Media stuff they can't stop right as
if Trump wouldn't have fought the guy if
he was white right like that's the
stupidest part well right right like
we're defending now you know I would I
began my career at the NYPD uh uh Jeff
might not know that but I mean I've
never had a defendant of any color I
love the district attorney Prosecuting
them and the judge uranium look this is
so Preposterous an asinine I mean you go
back in Trump's history before he was a
politician he was partying with 50 Cent
P Diddy like every you go back far
enough he probably played a set with The
OJ's I mean this guy you know I mean
that's never been an issue with Donald
Trump the guy was being celebrated by
Jesse Jackson and Al Sharpton back in
the 80s and 90s so it's a Preposterous
narrative yeah and if I'm not mistaken
Mar-A-Lago was the first club in Palm
Beach to allow Jewish people in I mean
the idea that they're still going with
this but they cannot stop you guys are
going to be completely shocked right now
because every now and again something
sane happens or at least roughly saying
happens on CNN and Van Jones who is
sometimes sane sometimes completely
insane he I think he sort of said
something same here related to all all
of this I mean I'm throwing this up to
the channel does this hurt the other
cases uh right now being pursued I I
worry I mean look if this is the only
Pebble that gets thrown at Donald Trump
uh it's a very small pebble if it's the
first Pebble in an avalanche of other
indictments that strike more to the
heart of I think people's core concern
about Donald Trump which is his threat
to democracy so this is the first Pebble
the next one is about the election
interference in Georgia the next one is
about the the the the the coup the
Insurrection January 6th the next one's
about and hoarding these documents and
when why then it begins to fit but if
this is the only Pebble it's not much of
a pebble and I do it could uh the
backlash against this Pebble might cow
other people who might otherwise have
been courageous enough to step forward I
was going to say two observations first
to let this point you know today this
this morning we saw he had an away game
in a very unfriendly Stadium right
tonight he's got a home game in front of
a home crowd who are riled up it is it's
like a homecoming he'll be he'll be
he'll be jubilant
I should qualify my own remarks you know
sometimes van Jones says something sane
but he also is saying insane things at
the same time the core concern that most
people have is Donald Trump's threat to
democracy I mean I think half the
country right now thinks the other side
is a threat to democracy let's just put
that out there uh but my point on the
sanity side was that if this is the only
Pebble meaning that he's arguing in a
way that this isn't that much John what
do you think of the the case itself
right now these 34 charges it sounds
like most of them should have been
misdemeanors they've been boosted to
felonies you know we got Stormy Daniels
now what was Trump money the whole thing
is so confusing well well let me tell
you what the biggest problem is with
this case first of all the case is a big
nothing right I don't see how this ever
survives uh an appeal on the statute of
limitations issue alone but but here's
how Preposterous to 34 counts are there
they've charged 34 counts on the same
payout because it was done in
installments so when I worked in a
robbery interdiction unit this is
equivalent to me arresting someone for
armed robbery they walk into a bodega in
Queens Jeff and they stick a gun in the
in the clerk's face and they get 100
bucks out of the register but instead of
me charging one count of robbery in the
first degree because the clerk counted
out 10 10 bills for the hundred bucks I
charge 10 counts of robbery the D.A
would laugh at me and knock it down to
one count for a hundred bucks so that
alone is preposterous and I'll go as far
as to say unprecedented but I do think
Georgia and the FEDS are going to come
with subsequent indictments that might
have a little bit more meat this knew
your case to me is frivolous nonsense
now a New York City judge is never going
to dismiss this I should say it's 98
chance they won't dismiss it Anything
could happen but I don't see how this
could ever survive on an appeal Jeffrey
let me let me ask you like a blue sky
question here which is my argument has
been whether these charges were as
ridiculous as John is laying out or
whether there was more meat to them the
bigger issue here is that once we start
charge
ex-presidents with crimes like this
especially things that they did having
nothing to do with their time in office
right the thin pool that we already have
of people willing to take the jump and
become president will become even
thinner and then out of that pool the
people that become president will never
want to leave power because they know
they're going to end up in jail I mean
that is that is the definition basically
of a Banana Republic well not to mention
a complete Distortion of the court
system that a justice system which you
know we don't have that much trust in at
all but uh the complete weaponization of
the courts and politicization of the
courts is not going to be good for
any cause Justice fairness equality or
even Western Civilization itself it's
this is anarchod tyranny and the courts
are you know can't become part of that
or else we've lost all hope let me just
quickly tell you about an op-ed that
appeared in the New York Times their
favorite newspaper uh former New York
former newspaper former newspaper the
New York Times New York Times times
which you know tells us tells they
always tell you where where things are
headed so there's an article this
morning that starts off by saying uh
well they finally got Trump and it goes
on to say well it's true that the
charges are pretty thin and there's not
much going on here
however this is brilliant that it's
happening it's what she called karma
Justice now karma Justice is not Justice
in the old fashioned sense it's just we
hate this guy let's get him that's
called karma justice so that's her whole
article is like we basically we hate
this guy so how whatever we can do to to
get rid of him is uh is Justified that's
what the karma would dictate so we're
gonna we're gonna turn the justice
system in this country into just purely
a discernment of both Karma who we like
and we don't like Prosecuting people we
don't like and and set free the people
who do that but then we're tending in
that direction it's it's it's it's it's
it's egregious now it's a follow-up for
from where everything has happened over
over three years and in many ways but
but it's nonetheless uh truly tragic and
especially alarming that you see the New
York Times come into the defense of what
they call Karma Justice which is not
Justice at all John speaking of karma
Justice as a former NYPD guy you know
what always used to happen with the
mafia guys would be that you know they'd
have all these massive real crimes right
and then they'd catch them on some sort
of nonsensical crime that's what always
would take people out in a weird way
that does feel like that could happen
here even though you're saying that the
charges are trumped up probably all gets
thrown out but doesn't it feel a little
bit like that like oh he must have done
all of these horrible karmic things but
we're gonna get him on this nonsensical
thing yeah that's exactly what it is I
mean and to our previous point you know
all the Wise Guys just loved Rudy
Giuliani they smell they showered him
with praise when he was Prosecuting not
luck it's so true this is this is
exactly what what this is and at Jeff's
point about the uh the downfall of
Western Society I agree with him I don't
think that's hyperbole I think the
United States has been a beacon because
of our stable government because of our
system of justice and the fact that
there were multiple things baked in that
kept it fair and this is eradicating all
that if you don't have the United States
you have nothing you have nothing and
that's what's what's so egregious about
this I have to agree with you that word
but uh I mean karmic Justice I mean lady
Lady Justice is sobbing and resigning
today that that we are now legitimizing
the New York Times the newspaper of
record right was when we were kids for
years but let me digress that's another
problem Trump as a boomer still
fundamentally believes in these
institutions yeah so he could say fake
news fake news fake news but then Maggie
Haberman gets a four-hour audience and
he calls her his therapist because he's
still fundamentally believes the New
York Times is somewhat like it was when
he was a kid when he was a young adult
and he would lick his thumb and turn the
page right so that's another problem and
that he legitimized these Outlets to to
a large degree so now you've got you've
got them biting him in the ass quite
frankly with these Preposterous stories
and I I think that we need we need
judges to stand up and prosecutors from
both sides of the aisle not that it'll
ever happen and just throw a flag and
blow a whistle right call an audible
here call a time out because they're
they're running down a path that's going
to be uh irreparable they're never going
to be able to pull this back they're
never going to be able to put this horse
back in the barn if they let this go too
far well I hate to tell you that's not
going to happen Johnny but Jeffrey what
do you think about what do you think
about that idea that basically Trump and
the media are a match made in Hell
together meaning that as much as he
rails against them he gets them clicks
he gets them views he goes to Maggie
Haberman at the same time while he's
calling it The failing New York Times
and that in a weird way that makes him
part of the machine now because the
machine is so built around response to
him that's a funny critique uh the
problem of trump is that he has too much
trust in the system
but he does
crazy right I mean a big media never
thrived more than it than it exactly it
did except and Trump's uh Trump's
presidency and they're they're aware of
this uh you know there's a there's a
theory floating around out there and I
don't think it's entirely crazy what
they're trying to do is first of all get
clicks and get more views and everything
and nobody's better than that for them
than Donald Trump but get them the
nomination and they think they can be
beat him uh you know based on all the
reading of the polls and their
experiences and and um
in 2018
2020 and 2022 they think uh Trump is
somebody they can beat and they're
terrified of somebody like DeSantis who
you know is potentially a real winner so
I mean that's sort of a an interesting
point of view but it's it's actually
widely shared in fact the Wall Street
Journal floated uh that story the other
day that this is ultimately this the
circus is a great benefit to uh to all
the people who've prevailed over the
last three years and and uh and
ultimately they're they're trying to use
Trump and worse than that Trump likes to
be used John what do you think about
that because it's that does ring right
to me it's like where can Trump get new
voters I get that this might energize a
certain amount of people but we're still
you know we're still a year and a half
away from an election but but let's say
okay the base is now energized where are
the new people where it's fairly obvious
that a guy like DeSantis can bring in
tons of new people look what's going on
here in Florida and the amount of
liberals who now vote for a republican
on top of the fact that guys like Joe
Rogan have said they would vote for
DeSantis did not vote for Trump Elon
Musk said he would vote for DeSantis did
not vote for Trump Etc so there is some
meat to this it's not just like some
crazy Theory yeah yeah right I mean take
take uh take um
you know uh some of those people out of
the equation you and I have had this
conversation offline Dave I I don't
think Trump has any new voters to
convert right I think he's he's losing
ground with moderates Independents and
npas and one of the biggest problems for
America I'm not going to say for Trump
or America is that the only Trump
supporters the most vehement supporters
and his Consultants who are out there
you know going nuts on Twitter and other
social media they're messaging for a
primary
these charges they're fundraising on
these charges for a primary the problem
with that though is those things repel
Independence moderates and non-party
Affiliated who just want to get back to
some sense of normalcy after coven and
after impeachments and after indictments
the other thing the other intangible
here that nobody's factoring and I can
tell you from the law enforcement side
there were times I felt bad for
non-violent defendants because a
criminal trial is about the most
emotionally mentally spiritually and
physically draining thing a human being
can endure now take a 76 year old human
being who's lived a Charmed Life who's
never had real trouble yeah civil suits
big deal you give it to your lawyer it
goes away you pay a couple of bucks or
maybe you win now you add a couple of
other indictments we know in New York
they're not even going to have their
next appearance until December 4th I
think yeah right it's insane so now
you've got Georgia and the feds and I
think Alvin Brad gave them both cover to
indict I don't care if you're a marathon
Runner a former Navy SEAL who was also a
Delta operator you are not going to
stand up to those things and not be
physically drained mentally drained
emotionally drained I don't see how you
can face three of these cases in three
different jurisdictions still run a
presidential campaign still do rallies
it would be it would be just an
anomalous Act of nature for that to
happen and I think people are
underestimating what this is going to do
to the guy in that sense financially
Millions upon millions and Trump isn't
that liquid if he was he wouldn't have
to pay out an installments right he's
never hidden the fact that he has assets
but he's not super liquid and so people
are really underestimating that and I I
do agree I think the Democrats want him
because they know his people will
primary message they'll win the primary
right if there's not a two more cases I
think that's all in doubt but if these
if it's only this one to your case and
it goes away and then I think he is
going to get obliterated it's going to
be a landslide in the general because
they'll have lost all of those Centrist
voters that are forgotten about in the
primary that's right let's let's hear
Trump himself on the charges
aren't big fans have said it they said
this is not the right thing to do
it's an insult to our country as the
world is already laughing at us for so
many other reasons like our open borders
are incompetent withdrawal from
Afghanistan Where We Left Behind
American citizens 85 billion dollars
worth of
the best military equipment in the world
lost 13 magnificent young lives and far
too many
to mention that are so badly hurt with
the loss of arms and legs and facial
obliteration
the most embarrassing time in our
country's history in my opinion
they want to settle the case but I want
no part of that
[Applause]
you know Jeffrey to to John's point
there you know he basically read the
entire speech right he didn't have his
crazy off-the-cuff moments the energy
seemed a little low and maybe that
really is part of it they feel that they
can just kind of grind him down long
enough flying to New York that day and
back give the speech 76 years old let's
roll this for a year and a half and and
the magic of what Trump is that I think
probably you know attracted half of the
country at least at one time to him
would would sort of dwindle yeah
uh I didn't think the speech was so bad
but I what I was intrigued by most with
that Soliloquy is his his March uh
through his own victimization right so
he goes through the Russia hoax and the
Ukraine thing and then uh uh you know he
marched ahead to the uh to the ballot
controversies around the uh and then and
then the FBI rate of his headquarters
went through everything there was a
glaring hole in his narrative and it
concerned everything that happened
between March uh 10th and and and and
his and the election which was the covet
lockdowns which he is subject and then
warp speed subjects he does not want to
talk about it either everybody knows
that Mar-A-Lago never bring this up and
yet that was the most mental momentous
attack on on on Western conception of
Rights and Liberties uh probably since
the Magna Carta and you've looked if you
can consider the scale I mean three
years ago this this weekend we weren't
allowed to go to church that was I'm
sorry Trump greenlighted that so now he
wants us to forget about it I mean he's
forgotten about it therefore it doesn't
matter you know the country was in
shambles by the time November arrived
and he wanted to just pretended it
didn't even matter so that's what stood
out to me that speech was not so much
what he said but what he didn't say so
to me uh he's he's part of this whole
plot to memory hole this astonishing
catastrophe and pretend like he had
nothing to do with it yeah
John bring us home on this one I suspect
Us in Florida are not going to let this
thing be memory hold because it because
it was done right here it's why I moved
here and you were here far longer than I
was
yeah I mean look I'm with Jeffrey on
this one I'll I'll make it a little more
succinct Trump's 2016 message was
optimistic right it was it was look at
my life I'm wealthy I'm famous you can
live like me let's make America great
again let's restore the American dream
you can live like me Trump's 2023 24
messages oh my God my life is in
shambles give me money help me pay my
legal bills look what they're doing to
me woe is me I'm the victim that's not a
winning optimistic message by any
stretch of the imagination and it's not
just Florida I mean I don't think people
anywhere are going to let this be Memory
old New York I think he's in trouble in
the New York primary because people died
in nursing homes and he wasn't out there
condemning Cuomo I think what's damning
for Trump is is a is the clip he did
with Candace Owens where when Candice
owes people forgot about this but I I
think this is going to be replayed
during the primary and the general when
Candace asked him why he didn't fire
fauci and he said well he's been there a
long time you don't just fire a guy like
that dude you ran on drain the swamp and
now you're saying that if people have
been part of the swamp for too long you
can't fire them I mean there is so much
Oppo out there on him with his coveted
response you could only use that and
he's incredibly vulnerable so yeah I
don't think this is going to be memory
hold by his primary Challengers and
certainly not by uh Democrats and their
Pacs in the general yeah and before we
move on to both your points I mean look
he was the one that that so proudly did
warp speed and yet his base the people
that love him the most are the most
anti-covered vaccine people that there
are I didn't get vaccine I include
myself in that group to that point
except he's the one that sped up the
thing to make sure that everybody got it
and then was still telling people even
months ago when he was on stage with
Bill O'Reilly what was that six months
ago still telling people to get it so
all right let's leave it there uh the
other big story which barely got
reported on is that the US dollar is
basically in free fall and we are
watching a complete realignment of the
world monetary policy Z here is Will
Kane from Fox News uh talking a bit
about the realignment that we're seeing
related to the dollar right now couldn't
announce this week that Russia will
begin using the Chinese Yuan uh for
international payments instead of the
dollar Saudi Arabia is also in talks
with Beijing to do the same thing
speaking of Saudi Arabia meanwhile they
are in talks uh with Iran as well to
consider an economic alliance with China
and Russia and they can even be joining
the bric countries which is an acronym
for these countries here Brazil Russia
India China and South Africa these
countries all have emerging economies
Jeffrey this is your department as an
economist
um this is not good it's almost as if
endlessly printing money based on
nothing here in the United States was
not only going to have problems for our
wallets but actually how countries treat
us and who they align with
uh yeah I would say that's that's right
uh the big problem for the U.S in terms
of the the the dollar is the
international Reserve currency concerns
also it's trade policies from 2018 to
the present I mean the U.S proved itself
to be an unreliable trading partner with
with random dictates so now we're going
to add five percent taxes under Goods
now there's some 10 now the 15 or 25
percent so what's the basis for it oh
it's the trade deficit wait that's bad
economics what are you doing uh we've
had more or less you know consistently
lower tariffs and global trade since uh
the end of World War II and now we're
just changing all the rules so that's
what Doom did and then the attack on
Russia the sanctions on Russia and the
confiscation of assets of a dollar
denominated was a way of saying if you
use the dollar we can we can we can lock
your accounts we can steal from that was
a terrible decision so it was both both
Trump's trade policies and the by
Administration sanction Russia just made
it inevitable but now we look around the
world and my God you know Iran Brazil
China Saudi Arabia Russia you know
everybody's turning against it so you
know how long is this going to take
before the dollar is unseated as the
international Reserve currency I think
it's going to be a while but what
matters here is the trajectory and it it
doesn't look good and as you implied
we've got other problems with the dollar
here at home uh namely it's it's
domestic value in terms of goods and
services the pce
who came out the data came out the other
day it's a fed's favorite inflation
measure and the services side of it
showed the largest increase in 12 months
which suggests that the Federal Reserves
uh interest rate policies of forever
raising rates are not not actually
concrete inflation that the uh 6.5
trillion dollars that they printed over
two years after this covet thing began
you know has to become endemic 5.5
trillion of that went into the banks
which they used to buy long-term bonds
that turned out to be devalued once the
federal reserve's policy came along and
that's destabilize the financial and
banking system even while real median
wages for Americans are going
dramatically down and credit card debt
is going up and it's costing ever more
to service that so you know we've got a
candle burning both both ends and also
getting thinner you know at the same
time it really is a disaster for U.S uh
prosperity and influence around the
world and to really just dumb that down
I mean everyone can see this happening
right in front of them inflation's going
up things cost more your money is worth
less and then with the interest rates
growing going up now you can see people
can't get loans so now the housing
market is freezing like and it's
happening across the entire country uh
John you're an international relations
guy I mean seeing these alliances kind
of come together this is not
particularly surprising right especially
when you throw in what's going on in
Ukraine and some new alliances happening
over there this is this is kind of 101
when you have inept us leadership huh
yeah I mean it is look Jeff summed it up
uh Jeffrey summed it up perfectly and
eloquently and and really
comprehensively I pretty much agree with
every word he said you know and so Dave
you know what I'm doing these days right
a private Equity guy and I do a lot of
imports of things from the Balkans
region Etc they still want to deal with
the US dollar they still do see the US
dollar as their best bet but I will tell
you something else that's starting to
concern many of these countries and
China and Russia are laughing at us
places like uh India are laughing at us
and uh is is this uh is this policy now
to put Dei and ESG over profits right so
when you combine everything Jeffrey said
and then you look at our banks or
debanking profitable businesses you and
I have had this conversation Ad nauseam
the banking profitable businesses
because of the type of Industry they're
in or where their ESG score they're not
diverse enough and then you've got
corporations like Budweiser and now Jack
Daniels buying into the trans you know
Mafia is uh thuggery and and are
starting to lose market share their
orders are being canceled by Massive
liquor Distributors but it's not just
liquor it's across the board no you'd
have to be kind of crazy to not see the
U.S economy the U.S economy and the US
dollar with a skeptical eye because
things we're doing here are just
inexplicable and this isn't isn't uh my
opinion even though it's anecdotal this
is what I'm hearing from the entities uh
over in Europe from whom we buy you know
massive quantities of goods they're
concerned right and people go well wait
a minute could this ESG thing really be
doing any of this and the diversity
equity and inclusion and all that and
the answer is yes Silicon Valley Bank
only had a chief risk officer for about
three months then did all these crazy
loans and they had a massive diversity
equity and inclusion department so
you're basically just bringing in people
that are not qualified because of their
genitals and skin color and you're not
taking care of the Departments that
actually make sure you do the proper
things as a bank I want to show you guys
one more video this is former uh
president of South Africa talking about
how the new Russia China Alliance
basically renders the US dollar
irrelevant
many countries are saying
in order to avoid this consequence
of the imposition of the sanctions by
the United States
on the basis that you are using their
currency
in order to avoid the consequences of
sanctions that arise from that let's
walk away from the dollar
enhance the
the global discussion taking place yeah
about that and it's some of it is
bilateral
when Russia are trades with China
there's no reason why they must create
used dollars to exchange none and so
that even India is saying the same thing
Jeffrey call me cynical here but I think
this is what the Democrats want I can't
say this is what Biden wants because I
don't think he's in charge nor really
understands what's going on actually but
I think that the the Democrats who are
not proud of America did not want
America to ever be a superpower
certainly not the last remaining super I
think they're happy that the dollar will
not be the currency of the world and
that our place in the world will just
sort of sink to
well probably lower than lower than any
of us would like let's put it that way
several years ago a movie came out
called The Joker uh it's good to
re-watch I think pretty much uh the DNC
and the Democrats generally sort of
embody everything about the Joker and
purely destructionist agenda getting
thrilled about unraveling everything
America has been and all of its
institutions and make a mockery of our
patriotic songs uh make a mockery of of
our freedom and our rights and so
certainly the Constitution and along
with that is tearing down the free
enterprise system that Bud Light ad last
week was just yeah just beyond belief
the corporate America is now you know
completely corrupt I don't know if
you've read Jennifer says book she's a
former she was in line to be the CEO of
Levi's and they canceled her during uh
Kobe because she wanted her kids to be
able to go to school right right right
right I didn't read this but I know what
you're talking about yeah yeah the book
is absolutely chilling just what's
what's happened to the to the culture of
of the higher ends of of American
corporate culture is entirely woke
alienated from from the American public
I mean you have 15 years of zero
interest rates uh LED you know a
generation or two to get these high-end
degrees from woke universities and then
not have real jobs in Corporate America
except for the CSG and Dei stuff it has
led to a kind of a an intellectual
cancer that spread throughout the entire
corporate American sector and it stuck
up on me Dave I didn't see it I think
you saw it coming before I did I was a
little bit naive about this but you
forget I I was a lefty I was in the
belly of the Beast you know I was I I
think you and I did an interview and I
was warning you about you know Trump's
authoritarian ways and you're like yeah
but there's other bad things Brewing
here too and I said yeah maybe you know
I didn't I didn't quite see it or
understand it but wow is it just it's
just packs a punch and it's and it's
grim and I you know it's weird at some
point you wonder how do you turn this
how do you turn this around I don't want
to be hopeless about it but at the very
least we need to talk about it and be
aware of it if we're going to do
anything about it
um I'm actually
uh super thrilled at Trends in labor
markets these days
because the zoom the zoom class uh
corporate Elite is all the sort of
losing their job I mean uh Elon Musk
sort of set the tone for everything you
know and now you're seeing it hit it you
know sector after sector as it's
actually great meanwhile all these jobs
are opening up in hospitality and Retail
imagine the esgdi uh Elite corporate set
having to face customers for the first
time in their life that that would be an
interesting thing imagine having to be
responsible to your shareholders or
build a good product or do something
that's worthy of putting on the market
uh John you know this sort of reminds me
when I was listening to the South
African former South African president
when you see these new alliances show up
we're both friends with uh former
ambassador to Germany Rick Grinnell and
obviously he's big in Trump World and
and he was also acting uh intelligent
secretary one of the things that he
would always say publicly and privately
is that how proud uh other countries
were that America was doing the right
thing under the Trump Administration and
when I see now Russia and China kind of
getting in bed together and Saudi Arabia
is coming around and now Iran's coming
everyone's kind of I'm pretty much
thinking every other country on earth is
like damn I wish America was back but
not with this guy we gotta move on yeah
yeah not not with not with this guy at
all not with this guy at all and and uh
is it just me or every time I see that
South African guy it looks like the
makeup Department aged Don Cheadle and
then I realize he's a real guy but but
no well there goes our YouTube channel
all kidding aside the uh the um when I
travel I travel to Europe quite often to
the Balkans and I hear this and you know
Rick is a good friend we do some
business together these days they tell
me I've I've had people over in the
Balkans various Nations say what the
hell is going on in your country what
are these Democrats doing are they
trying to destroy you from within so to
your point Dave yeah I think John Kerry
would love nothing more than to go to
Paris and to go to the EU and sit before
that Council and say hey give me a pat
on the head didn't I do good with
kicking the dollar out we've given to
China the uh The prominent position
didn't I finally do good come on Pat me
on the back and invite me to dinner
party so absolutely I think the
Democrats would love nothing more than
to weaken us
guys I thank you for your time
unfortunately I'm a little tight today
so we have to wrap it up there but uh we
will definitely do this again with the
two of you uh ladies and gentlemen my
full interview with my congresswoman it
was the first time I ever met her Maria
Salazar is up across platforms right now
uh no post game show cause I gotta get
out of here but we will be back on
Monday have a great uh weekend great
Easter happy Passover everybody we'll
see you on Monday thanks Dave great to
see you Dave great to see you John